So this week we're going to talk about about biomechanics.
Let me do this a different way.
Sorry.
Uh,
we're going to talk about biomechanics and the reading is chapter 10.
I think on your syllabus it says chapter 10 and 13,
but we're really only going to talk about chapter 10 during class.
And then our section on Thursday will also involve two aspects of biomechanics,
talking about materials,
properties,
which is what I'm going to focus on in the lecture today.
And thinking about some elementary gait analysis gate to ga it or how,
uh,
how humans walk and run and the mechanics of that.
A particular kind of motion.
So this is like many of the other topics that we've covered,
uh,
in,
in the course.
A very big subject.
And some of you I have no doubt are going to go on to,
to study biomechanics in greater detail.
So I've picked a couple of things that I thought were interesting to sort of
teach you sort of the elements of mechanics.
How do I use physics to think about biological materials and um,
and uh,
and how organisms live in a physical world.
And so today we're going to talk about properties of biological materials in
particular to,
uh,
properties,
elasticy,
city and viscosity.
And we'll talk about how most real biological materials,
your skin,
your brain,
the,
um,
the gel that makes up the interior portion of your,
I have both of those qualities.
They're both viscous and elastic,
and they exhibit something that we call visco elastic city.
And so by the end of the lecture today,
you should know a little bit about what visco elastic city is and how materials
that have that property behave and the,
and most biological materials have the that property.
And then on Thursday we're going to talk about locomotion.
How do animals move in particular,
how to humans move?
And we'll talk about three kinds of motion.
Uh,
the most interesting one may be flying that humans don't do unaided.
but it's interesting to think about how flight is possible from a mechanical
perspective.
How do organisms release themselves from the gravitational field and learn how
to move,
uh,
in,
in a flight.
We'll talk about swimming and we'll talk about running
or walking.
So first,
the mechanical properties of biological materials.
And these are the two questions that I want to focus on during the lecture
today.
And,
uh,
the two questions that you should be able to answer by the end.
What is the lasting city?
How do would I measure the plasticity?
How would I quantify?
Elasticy city might be other ways to think about that question.
And what is visco elastic city?
How do visco elastic materials differ from elastic materials?
And how does that make them different in biological,
um,
when,
when they're part of a biological organism.
So we're going to think about this simple experiment that's a,
that's shown,
uh,
schematically on the top here in panel a of this diagram.
So we assume we have some material and this could be anything,
but let's think about it in the simplest possible way.
It's some uniform material,
uh,
at least initially.
Uh,
so it may be it's a steel,
maybe it's rubber plastic,
maybe it's some biological material,
like a muscle or some other kind of tissue,
skin,
an artery.
And,
um,
but let's just think about rubber for the beginning.
Maybe even a rubber band and you hang the rubber band from some solid support
that's unmovable,
like the ceiling here.
So we have some way of a fixing this solid material to the ceiling and we can
measure some properties of the material,
mechanical properties of the material.
For example,
it has a length and it has a cross sectional area.
And when we do mechanical testing,
we're trying to understand how that material behaves when it's exposed to
forces,
right when it's exposed to the forces that encounters in the physical world.
And so we want to set up an experiment where we can apply a force uniformly and
measure the result of that force simply.
And so the experiment I show here is just to hang a weight on that material
that's suspended from the ceiling,
that rubber band,
for example,
I hang a weight on it.
And so that w that weight
apply some force to the material,
right?
Because it's gravity is gonna pull it down with some force based on its mass.
And for most materials,
certainly for rubber bands,
if I put them on the,
fix them to the ceiling that way.
And attached to weight.
What would happen?
They would lengthen,
they'd get longer because they're exposed to that weight.
And so I've applied a force
and I've experienced a defamation,
right?
I've applied a force and the material has deformed and I'm going to quantify
that and I can quantify that fairly easily because I chose a simple material
that had a constant cross sectional area from the top to the bottom.
So I'm going to assume that that cross sectional area,
it doesn't change when it deforms,
but I hang the weight on it and the length increases.
So the length is now l plus Delta l.
And so I can quantify the defamation here by defining a property called strain.
And the strain is just the change in length divided by the total length.
Now important what length we use here and we we're,
we're going to use the initial length as the length,
right?
So the strain is the change in length divided by the length in the unstressed
position.
Unstressed orientation on stressed condition,
that's the right word.
S does that make sense?
So this is a measure of how much it deforms.
And we're going to define the stress and stress is just force per unit area.
Cause you can imagine if I hang the same weight on this material,
if it's a material that has a large cross sectional area,
it's very thick or it's a material that's very thin,
then it's defamation is going to be different because that force is going to be
distributed over either a big area or a small area.
And so the stress is just equal to the force per area.
And we're going to assume that we arranged it in some way that it's uniform over
the area
so it makes it so the experiment makes sense.
Hanging from the ceiling,
suspended one,
one,
one end is held rigid.
I put a weight on it,
I watch it to form,
I measure the defamation that occurs as a result of applying that stress.
Okay.
Now to analyze how this material behaves under different stress conditions,
right?
So I might want to know how does the muscle of my thigh behave when it
experiences different kinds of affirmations,
right?
What stress builds up when I stretch it out,
for example.
Um,
because I'm interested in the mechanics of running.
And so what I want to know is what is the defamation that occurs in this
particular muscle when I've applied different forces are different stresses to
it.
And so the way that I would measure that is by just applying different forces,
right?
Start with,
start with a small force at a larger force,
at a larger force,
and then measure the defamation at each of those conditions.
And if I did that,
I could plot on this diagram here.
Stress versus strain.
Okay,
now the strain.
Remember just Delta l over l the stress,
just the force divided by the area.
But I would get different points on this curve and each one would represent a
different experiment where I added a different force and eventually I could draw
a line through it.
Now think back again to the first example I said the simple example just to
rubber band.
If you did this experiment with a rubber band,
you hung different forces on it.
What would you see as you,
as you put more weight on,
the rubber band would stretch more and more and more.
So the strain would go up and in fact up to a certain amount of force.
If I measured the strain that results from forces,
I would get a straight line,
okay,
I could plot stress versus
strain and I would get a straight line and that a material that behaves that way
is called an elastic material.
That's,
that's an elastic material,
a perfect elastic material.
I could apply those forces,
it would stretch out,
and if I took the forces away,
it would go right back up again.
And at the end of the experiment of adding more weight than taking the weight
off the material be exactly the same as how it started.
That's an elastic material that's perfectly reversible,
right?
A perfect elastic material.
Now,
I could tell you everything you need to know about the elastic properties,
that material by giving you one number,
the slope of this line.
Because once you knew the slope of this line,
you could draw the curve that represents all of it's stress strain behavior.
So instead of someone else having to do this experiment again,
you could just tell them,
oh,
for those rubber bands I measured the elasticity and the elasticity or the slope
of this line is some number.
He this,
this letter he is called the elastic modulus or the Young's modulus.
And um,
it's,
um,
it's a characteristic of the material for this material in this particular
geometry.
That's the elastic modulus,
that and,
and,
and someone who knew that would know how to predict how that material behaves,
at least under the conditions in which you did the experiment.
Does that make sense?
Now,
if you've studied physics in the past,
I assume most of you have in high school,
then you've thought about perfect elastic materials.
What did you call a perfect elastic material in physics?
What do you remember studying a perfect elastic material in physics
a spring?
That's exactly what it spring is.
And when you talked about springs,
you talked about a spring constant,
which was how to relate the force to the elongation.
This is exactly the same thing,
but it's sort of described in a different way,
right?
Because now you're talking about a real material that has cross sectional area,
not an imaginary spring,
but when you thought about springs and spring constants,
you were thinking about this exact same physical process.
We're just describing it in a different way now.
And in fact,
by the end of the lecture,
we'll come back to thinking about springs as,
um,
as a way of idealizing or describing,
uh,
materials that have complex properties.
Okay.
Until this spring,
the imaginary object that you talked about in physics is just an idealization of
real materials and how they really behave when forces are applied to them.
Okay?
Okay.
If you continue to add force,
then at some point,
at some point the material's not going to behave perfectly elastically anymore
and you'll see that because it's not a straight line anymore,
it's not linear.
So it still might be elastic,
but it's not linearly elastic.
So can't describe it by just the slope anymore.
And at some point for any material,
you could add enough weight that it's going to fail.
Okay.
And,
uh,
you could define the stress at failure when the material physically breaks or
the strain at failure when it physically doesn't function as a material anymore
for the rubber band.
You had so much force that it breaks and there's some weird behavior that starts
to happen,
uh,
when it,
when it's in that mode of starting to fail in that,
um,
some of the assumptions that we made don't hold any longer.
For example,
the assumption that the,
that the cross sectional area stays the same.
You know,
if you stretch out a rubber band,
if you stretch it so,
so,
so much the cross sectional area is going to start to cave in at one point.
Not along the whole rubber band but at some point.
And so it doesn't even behave,
uh,
in the way that stress continuously goes up with strain any morning.
And that's because of the way we've defined it.
Okay.
The simple experiment makes sense.
So lets imagine then that we're doing this experiment where we've got the
material attached to the ceiling and it's a,
it's a,
it's a rubber band still and we're adding weight to it.
And so one way to think about that is that we're going from the 0.0 the totally
unstressed material and we're adding more weight.
We're going up towards point a here,
right?
And so we're moving towards point a by adding more weight to the material and
it's stretching out as we're adding more weight,
we're applying more stress,
we're experiencing or observing more strain.
If I go up to point a,
I can come back down from point a by taking the weights off and the material
will follow exactly the same path back along the same stress strain curve.
So I could stretch the material,
I could return the material to its original state,
I could stretch it,
I could return it to its original state.
That's a,
that's a reversible elastic material at the beginning.
It's you at the beginning,
it has one property,
you stretch it out,
you let it come back and it's the same as it was at the beginning.
That's a perfectly elastic material.
If you overstretch and material that is,
you go instead of point B,
you add so much weight instead of point a you add so much weight that you go up
to point B.
When you take the weight off,
it might not follow the same stress strain behavior coming back down and in this
case it follows this different curves,
the dotted line here.
Now what does that mean?
What?
What would you really have observed when you did this experiment that ended up
being plotted this way that I was adding weight,
I was stretching out the material and I stretched it so much that I actually
changed the material.
It can't go back to its original shape anymore,
but when I take the weight off,
it's permanently deformed,
right?
When I take the weight off,
it follows this line back and even at zero stress,
it still has some defamation,
meaning it's longer than it was when I started.
And you've had this experience with rubber bands or balloons.
If you play with it enough,
you stretch it,
you're really stretch it and now it doesn't go back to its original shape
anymore.
And if you look at the rubber band,
it physically looks different.
There might be a part that's narrower or the texture of it looks different
because it's stretched in one direction.
Or you physically deformed the material beyond its Plat,
beyond its elastic limit.
And you've created what's called a plastic defamation.
You've changed the material so it's not the same anymore.
Okay.
And that's going beyond the elastic limit,
which in this case might be a,
and you've,
you've created not just an elastic defamation,
but a plastic deformation that materials now forever changed.
Maybe there's some ways that you can get it back,
but probably not.
It's like,
Yep,
anybody have a slinky
that's a,
that's a sixties toy,
right?
And play with slinkies,
but maybe had slightly,
they used to be wire and you could cut yourself on them and now they're plastic,
right?
But they're,
these,
I need a nod that somebody else besides me knows what it's slinky is.
And,
and you're supposed to be able to make it walk down the stairs,
but it doesn't ever really work.
Uh,
but if you take a slinky,
you could stretch it out and they'll go back and stretch it out and go,
it's back.
But what if you have your brother,
your sister grab it and you pull it all the way across the room,
right?
The material gets physically deformed.
It doesn't go back any longer.
That's a plastic deformation of the slinky
phone cords the same way.
So you have a lot of experience with this in your,
in your real life,
you've used a phone that has a wire on it,
right?
Coiled.
Yeah.
Um,
so,
so if,
if we're just talking about elastic materials,
that means materials that have the property of elastic city and they haven't
been deformed beyond their elastic limit,
then I can stretch him.
They'll come back,
stretch them,
come back.
And I can do that as many times as I want and I'll always get the same material.
You could classify materials that are,
um,
that are elastic into different properties.
And now we're not just thinking about rubber bands,
but we're thinking about every material.
And so most materials have some elasticy it and over a certain range of stresses
they will deformed elastically,
steel deforms elastically.
You don't think about it doing that and you've got to apply really hard stresses
in order for the form.
But it does deform elastically would does under some conditions,
bones do all materials do under at least some range of stress conditions,
but some are going to be what's called more compliant.
That is there that at a given stress at it given force application,
they deformed more.
That's a compliant material.
One that's very stretchy or very elastic or stiff one that doesn't deform very
much.
When it stresses Diplo applied,
it's a stiffer material and less compliant material or brittle that is d deforms
even less and we'll break rather than uh,
rather than stretch very much.
Okay,
so you could define different classes of materials based on this property of
elasticy it.
Okay.
So that's one part of what I wanted you to understand today.
What's an elastic material?
How would I characterize it and what does it mean to be an elastic material?
The second thing I want to think about is is viscosity and viscosity is a
property that we associate with fluids,
right?
We,
we've talked about viscosity,
we talked about uh,
the viscosity of,
of,
uh,
of blood flowing through arteries for example,
on how viscosity contributed to the resistance of a vessel,
right?
It was,
it's,
it's in that relationship between pressure drop and flow.
Well,
let's think about another experiment where we have a fluid and we want to
measure its viscosity.
That is we want to measure what's its resistance to flow of the fluid.
And so a way to do that experiment,
and it turns out that there's a lot more practical ways than this,
but here's one way to do the experiment is to take a table like this one,
a solid surface that's not going to move and,
and,
and spread the liquid all over the surface.
Now let's forget for a minute about the fact that this table is only so wide.
It's a fluid is going to flow off the edges.
And let's assume that I could put a layer of fluid on here and it would stay and
then I could put another desktop on top of it.
So what I've created is a space between two desktops,
one which is fixed to the floor so it won't move.
And the other,
which is floating on top of a layer of fluid.
It's makes sense.
And so now you could imagine if you could do that,
if I had a layer of fluid here and another desktop sitting on top,
I could apply a force this way parallel to the surface.
And the thing would move easily,
right?
If it was water,
it would move very easily.
If it was alcohol,
the fluid,
it would move very easily.
If it was molasses,
it would move,
but I'd have to apply more force in order to move the desktop on the surface,
but I could do it.
Right.
Um,
so what you're really doing in that experiment I just described is the same
thing as the experiment we did when we hung the rubber band from the bill from
the top of the ceiling here is that I've applied a force and I've measured a
defamation.
Now the forest and the defamation are different in this case because now in
applying a force,
not intention,
right before I was talking about only applying forces,
intention to create a tense and force in the material.
Now I'm applying a force in sheer,
I'm trying to move one plate relative to another plate and I'm trying to move
them across each other,
right?
So that's a sheer force and the defamation is not a defamation like it increases
in length.
The defamation is that the wall on top moves
and it moves continuously,
right?
Imagine if I start to apply,
I have this set up here.
The desktop is on top of the layer of fluid on top of the desktop below,
and I somehow apply a constant force to that top plate,
that top desktop.
It's going to continue to move.
As long as I apply a constant force,
it'll move.
It will move,
it will move.
Eventually I'd fall off the desk here,
right?
So what's created is not a strain.
What's created is a velocity.
Okay?
The top plate is going to move and if I apply a constant force,
a constant shearing force to the top plate,
I will,
I will measure a velocity.
Does that make sense?
What's really happening in the fluid here is that within this fluid,
when I put the apply the force on the top plate,
the molecules of fluid that are right next to the top,
let me call it a plate now instead of a desktop,
because that's a shorter word,
that molecules of fluid that are right next to this top plate.
When I start to move it,
they move along with the top plate.
Those molecules of fluid experience some friction with a top plate,
and when I moved the top plate,
they move along with the molecule is a fluid that are just below that.
Also want to move along with it because there's some friction between the
molecules inside the liquid,
right?
There's some friction,
but it's not perfect friction it slips and viscosity is a measure of how Slippy
the fluid is.
Different layers of fluid,
how easily they slide by one another when they're shared.
So water,
because it has a low viscosity compared to molasses,
those layers of water are going to move easily over one another.
Whereas in molasses there's more friction between the layers and so it's harder
to move.
And in either case what will happen is that when I apply the forest,
the the law,
the packets of fluid up near the top are going to move along with the top plate.
The ones a little below it are going to move a little slower.
The ones below it are going to move a little slower than that.
Slower than that,
slower than that,
slower than that until the ones at the very bottom don't move at all because
they're experiencing friction from the bottom plate.
Right?
So if I could look,
if I could look microscopically at what happens when I share this top plate over
the bottom plate,
within the layer of fluid between,
I've created a velocity gradient where the fluid is moving very fast,
near the top plate,
slower in the middle,
and not at all at the surface of the bottom plate.
And by doing this,
I can measure the force that's required in order to establish that velocity
gradient,
right?
And I'm going to make the same kind of plot here that I made in,
in,
in uh,
stress versus strain for,
uh,
an elastic material.
But I'm going to plot different things instead of,
uh,
stress,
tension,
tensile stress,
I'm going to plot sheer stress.
And that is the amount of force that I've applied on this wall in order to get
it to move divided by the cross sectional area of the wall.
So it's the amount of force I had to apply in order to set this thing in
constant motion divided by its cross sectional area.
And what I'm going to plop down here is the rate of defamation because there is
no limit to the defamation here.
As long as I apply the force,
it's going to continue to slide.
Okay?
So I can't measure the strain because it will continuously to form.
There's no end to it.
What I can measure instead is the maximum velocity divided by the thickness,
the gap between the two walls or the height of the fluid.
So this velocity divided by height is a measure of the rate of defamation.
Does that make sense?
Okay.
So the kind of the same thing,
right?
I did an experiment set up a different way,
apply to force,
measured a defamation in this case,
sheer stress and rate of defamation.
And what I'd find here is that over a certain length,
over a certain range of forces,
I would get a straight line.
And the slope of that line is this property called the viscosity.
And for fluids that have a high viscosity like molasses or honey,
I have to apply a lot of force in order to achieve a certain velocity for fluids
that are less viscous like water.
I don't need to apply so much force in order to change that same velocity in
order to achieve that same velocity.
Does that make sense?
So here's another kind of material and there are biological materials that
behave this way.
Their mechanics are like this blood is one of them.
Blood is a viscous material and if I put between this here and I did this
experiment,
I would see roughly this behavior that as I increase the force,
I increase the velocity and it's linear and I could measure the viscosity.
Now it turns out that blood is a little bit different in that it turns out that
unlike water,
if I apply even the smallest force,
the plates going to move when it's water between here,
if it was blood,
it turns out that per small forces,
it doesn't move at all,
that I have to apply a certain amount of force in order to get it to move.
Why do you think it would be different for blood then for water?
What can you imagine that's different for blood?
The creates the situation that had very small forces.
It doesn't move at all,
but it has some yields,
force or yield stress that one has to get over in order to start it in motion.
What's different about blood and water?
It's thicker than water,
right?
You know that from
the Bible,
isn't that where blood is thicker than water code?
I don't even know.
Justin
has large molecules and red blood cells and it has red blood cells at a fairly
high volume fraction.
About 50% is blood cells.
And it turns out that to get those blood cells rolling,
to get them moving out of each other's way requires a certain amount of force.
And in fact,
when,
when blood is stagnant,
even if it's anti coagulated,
the blood cells tend to form structures where they align with one another.
And so it's hard to get that moving.
But for most of it's,
for most of its,
uh,
for most of the Shear stresses that are biologically important,
blood behaves is a viscous liquid.
It's about three times as viscous as water.
Okay,
so that's viscosity.
So you know about [inaudible] and this guy and uh,
and uh,
viscosity.
So let's take,
let's go back now to the material I talked about at the beginning.
And let's assume now that it's not a,
uh,
it's not a perfect elastic material,
but it's a material that is,
um,
that is different than that.
And let's do the experiment in a different way
or look at it and in a different way where I,
I'm still hanging the material from the ceiling and I'm still applying a force
to it and I'm asking how it deforms.
But now instead of just looking at his total defamation,
I want to look at how the defamation changes over time.
And time is an important variable in most biological processes.
You care not only about how much defamation I get when I apply a force,
but you care about how quickly I achieved that defamation,
right?
And how quickly materials can physically move when forces are applied.
So if this is a perfect elastic material like rubber band or like the springs
you learned about in physics,
when I apply a force here,
it instantaneously changes its length.
Deformations formations are instantaneous.
They take no time at all for a perfect elastic material.
And so how much would the deformation occur?
Well,
you,
it would depend on the elasticity,
but as soon as I added that force,
it's going to stretch out bang to that length and it's going to stay there.
You know,
real materials don't behave like this but,
but our perfect elastic material does,
if the material is visco elastic,
meaning it has properties of both the plasticity and viscosity,
like a muscle say,
um,
like the fluid that's inside your eye.
If I apply a force,
it's going to exhibit two different behaviors.
First it's going to elongate instantaneously,
just like the perfect elastic material wood.
And then it's going to continue to uh,
along gate slowly
it's going to continue to elongate.
And so I've shown that here,
if I look at the length versus time,
it's going to instantaneously along gate to some extent and then it's going to
slowly keep deforming.
Now that behavior where I apply a force and it goes initially out to here,
looks like elastic material.
The behavior where it continually starts,
continues to stretch out over time and gets longer and longer and longer.
That looks like a viscous material.
That's how a viscous material would behave.
I apply a force and it continuously to forms with some rate,
right?
And so this,
this material is behaving like an elastic solid and like a viscous liquid.
Both.
It's what we call a visco elastic material and most biological materials have
that property.
They have some viscosity that is they deformed continuously under stress and
they have some elasticy Catie,
they to form elastically under stress.
Another way to do this experiment would be not to hang a weight and then measure
what,
um,
what defamation occurs,
but to instead do the experiment as is shown in this diagram here,
which is stretch the material out suddenly and then measure the force that's
required to hold this apart
for an elastic material.
You'd get the same result.
If you,
if you apply a strain that is,
I just pull this up to some length,
it's going to take some force to do that and all the forest gets applied
instantaneously.
And then after that I just maintain the forest and I hold the material there for
a visco elastic material behaves differently and that an initial response will
be like an elastic solid.
It will,
it will you,
you stretch it out to its strain and it's going to take the same force to open
it up,
to stretch it out,
to deform it,
and then the material's gonna Relax and start to flow,
which what you would measure is that the force required to hold it at this
defamation starts to drop over time as the material itself rearranges and
deforms in order to accommodate that strain that you've put in it.
Does that make sense?
So two ways to do the experiment to different ways of looking at
viscoelasticity.
One is you apply a force and now you can see continuous defamation.
The other is that you apply a defamation and you see a change in force required
to hold that defamation over time.
It turns out that not all this go elastic materials exhibit the same behavior,
but there's a range of viscoelastic properties in that some viscoelastic
materials behave more like elastic solids,
some behave more like viscous liquids and some behaves somewhere in between.
And physicists have figured out ways,
models that they can use to explain how viscous materials behave.
And you could imagine that this would be important in biomedical engineering,
right?
For example,
if I want to understand how the leg works,
then a important part of how the leg works as a machine is understanding the
properties of the leg muscles,
right?
How they uh,
how they differ form under stress and how when a stresses are applied to them,
how that changes their shape,
how that's essential for,
if a muscle is going to contract and apply a force to your leg,
then you need to know how the strain or defamation of that muscle relates to its
ability to create a force,
right?
To pick up the leg for example,
or to move it.
MMM.
So I'd like some way to describe that mathematically.
I'd like some way to describe the stress strain behavior of complicated
biological materials like muscles.
And so one way to do that is to build models based on elements that I
understand.
So I understand the spring.
Okay.
I understand the spring and if it was a perfect,
if the muscle was a perfect elastic material,
I could describe all of its behavior by its spring constant or it's elastic
modulus and I would know everything about its stress strain behavior,
but muscles don't behave like strings because they have some viscous properties.
So what's a,
what's a simple example of a viscous material?
Well,
I gave you this example of the,
of the plate sliding over the,
over the layer of fluid.
Uh,
well there's another model that,
um,
that physicists use to describe a viscous materials.
And maybe you've seen this,
it's an element that you don't really encounter in life.
You encounter things like springs.
You don't encounter things like dash Potts very often.
And that's what this is called.
This is a dashpot.
And a Dashpot is a idealized physical model of a viscous liquid.
And one way to imagine it is that it's a cylinder.
The black cylinder here inside of a hollow cylinder.
Yeah.
So it's uh,
it's,
it's a cylinder inside of a hollow cylinder and there's some friction between
the outside wall of the black cylinder and the inside wall of the hollow
cylinder.
There's some well behaved,
well known friction between the inside of the hollow cylinder and the outside of
the inner cylinder.
Now then,
if I apply a force ply force down here in that direction to this Dashpot,
what's going to happen is that the inner cylinder,
it's going to slide over the outer cylinder,
slide through the outer cylinder,
and for a constant force,
since this is a,
this is a well behaved,
the friction between here as well known and well behaved,
it's going to just slide with a uniform velocity,
the inner cylinder over the outer cylinder.
Does that make sense?
So this dashpot is an idealized physical model for how a viscous liquid behaves.
I apply a force and it continuously deforms.
Okay.
Now it's a,
it's better as a thought experiment than a real experiment.
Cause you can imagine making things that behave like real,
real springs.
Real dash would be hard to make.
Why?
Because eventually,
no matter how long your outer cylinder,
why should eventually come out of it,
right?
So it's a real dashpot.
If it's going to to form for a long time would have to be infinitely long as
well.
So it's better as a thought experiment than a real thing to build.
But you get the thought experiment,
right?
So I have a spring here.
How will it behave when I put a force on it,
it's going to deform instantaneously to a certain length.
The length will depend on the force,
the Dashpot I apply a force to it.
How will it behave?
It's going to slowly deformed over time,
continuously with a constant rate,
but it will never stop deforming.
What would happen if I put a spring and a dashpot together like this?
That is,
I have a solid wall here.
I first attach the spring and I attach it Dashpot to the wall to the spring.
And now I apply a force.
Well this spring dashpot combination is going to have elastic properties.
It's going to have biscuits,
properties,
but it's going to behave in a certain way.
When I applied the force,
the force is going to be applied over the whole structure at once.
And so the the spring is going to fully experience that force and it's going to
stretch out.
The spring is going to fully experience that force and it's going to stretch
out.
And then the Dashpot is also going to experience that force and it's slowly
going to,
so what I would observe experimentally if I could build this spring dashpot a
combination is I'd see,
uh,
initial defamation and then continuous defamation after that.
And this is an example of one kind of visco elastic behavior.
If I took my muscle and I did measurements on it and I found experimentally that
it behaved like this,
then I would say,
oh,
I can describe how the muscle behaves by this simple thought experiment,
this simple mathematical construct of a spring.
And a dashpot connected together.
Okay,
that makes sense.
Well that's not the only way that you could create a viscous that you could
create an imaginary viscous visco elastic material.
I could also attach the spring and the dashpot in series.
That is a touch both the spring and the Dashpot to the wall,
have a little strut connecting them and then apply the force that way.
Right.
How would this material behave?
It would behave differently because when the force is applied,
the spring would like to stretch out but it can't.
It can't because it's constrained by the dashpot which only deformed slowly.
So the spring would like to deform,
would like to take all of the forest and deformed,
but it can't because the dashpot physically takes time to move.
It can only to form at some rate.
So in the initial period the dash bought is,
is taking all of the force.
Right.
And what you would see initially is a slow defamation.
Yeah.
Now while the dashpot would like to keep deforming forever,
this thing can't because the spring has a limit to how much it can stretch.
And so when you get up to the elastic limit of the spring or,
or the elasticity of the spring,
the spring is going to be taking all of the force
and the Dashpot,
then we'll have no force on it and it will stop to forming.
So,
uh,
Bisco elastic material that behaved like a spring and a dashpot in series would
have this behavior.
It would not have any initial defamation.
It would differ form slowly at first and then it would reach some maximum
defamation,
like an elastic solid,
but it would be evolving over time.
Right.
This makes sense.
Now these are two simple models of materials that have viscous and elastic
properties.
And so now I could measure real materials and I could see,
well,
do they act more like this?
Do they act more like this?
And I could use these thought constructs in order to describe those materials
and I could learn about the materials,
behave under unusual conditions.
That way I could predict start to predict how they behave.
It turns out that most real visco elastic materials don't obey either this model
or this model,
but you can build more complex ones,
right?
You could imagine having a a spring and a dashpot on this side and just a
dashpot over here.
Or You can imagine having three elements in series.
You could imagine all sorts of different ways of putting viscous elements and
elastic elements together to define an imaginary material.
You could then predict how that imaginary material is going to behave and you
can see how close it is to Rio materials.
What I want you to remember from this is a couple of different things.
One,
we talked about elasticy at the beginning,
how to purely elastic materials behave.
You know that how to purely viscous materials behave.
You understand that real materials,
real biological materials have our viscoelastic,
they have both elastic and biscuits properties,
but that doesn't mean just one thing.
That can mean a whole range of behaviors.
It's possible in some cases to define that whole range of behaviors by building
simple thought experiments are simple models like these spring dashpot
combinations.
But in general,
the viscoelastic real visceral elastic materials we see are more complex than
any of the,
they have more complex behaviors than any of the idealized models we put
together.
Although sometimes they come very close
questions.
Okay.
If you,
if you looked for the homework assignment over the weekend and then you look at
it today or yesterday,
you will have noticed that it changed.
It became simpler.
So I decided that first I had a homework assignment that had two parts.
The first part of it was to,
uh,
was to write an introductory paragraph for your paper and an outline for the
rest and turn it in.
And then there was some problems related to the material for this week from
chapter 10.
What I decided to do instead was asking you just to focus on your papers this
week and just turn in that introductory paragraph and the outline.
That's all the homework for this week.
And then we'll put off the homework assignments on this topic.
And what we'll talk about Thursday.
That won't be due until next Thursday.
Okay.
So I'd like for you to really focus on your research papers this week.
We'll come back,
like do the homework set next week,
and then the week after that,
there won't be any homework except just to finish your research papers and that
will be the week that it's due.
But just wanted you to keep that in mind because I know that timing and
balancing all of your responsibilities to different courses is critical at this
time of the year.
Questions about that?
Or,
or about,
uh,
what I talked about at the beginning.
Instructions for the paper here.
Reviewing
good.
See on Thursday.